welcome to this special episode of into
the impossible with yours truly dr brian
keating
today we're joined for a special lecture
by dr brandon hensley of princeton
university he
is a lyman spitzer fellow which is
quite an honorific lyman spitzer is the
father in some ways of the hubble space
telescope
and brennan is an expert on all things
cosmological but in particular
on the peccadillos of cosmic dust
that most mercurial substance that forms
the composition of our cosmos that leads
to
the creation of cosmic worlds like our
earth and the destruction of nobel
prizes
as you may have learned about in books
such as losing the nobel prize
over here over there and it actually
makes up
a good deal of the concern of the
of the pursuit that we have as
cosmologists trying to seek
out the birth pangs of the big bang in
the inflationary b mode polarization
it's an obstacle but it also provides us
a window on our galaxy to learn about it
it may also hamper our our
ability to measure the early universe's
other features such as its ability our
ability
to measure primordial parity violation
which is of great interest to physicists
i always say that
if we were to measure the violation of
lorentz invariant symmetry
that might be even more spectacular than
measuring
the departures that would be present and
revealed
by primordial b mode polarization
patterns many people suspect that
the universe underwent a brief period of
inflation or something like it
but almost no physicist believes that
special or general relativity exhibits
some form of parity violation or
some form of lorenz violation and
those types of claims have been made
recently cosmic parody violation
by miami and kamatsu i've had sean
carroll on
the show i'll put a link to that up here
in the card
and i'll put a link at the end as well
and that caused quite a stir
when that paper was released back in
uh back in late 2020. you'll see that
brandon is a little bit
skeptical about that along with his
colleague susan clark who is moving to
stanford to start an assistant
professorship there
they're both uh the co-leaders of this
paper that brendan's going to be
discussing
and they're both members of the simon's
observatory i can't be more excited
to have these geniuses as members of the
team
that i get to participate in that we are
in the midst of building despite the
many setbacks that we have along the way
with uh covid and other logistical
challenges were
uh hot and heavy on the trail to detect
the most mercurial of all cosmic signals
it's polarization so sit back and enjoy
this special lecture
very technical but i know you guys are
up to the challenge
and stay tuned for more great talks
we're gonna have a special lecture by
uh our special conversation with steven
strogatz coming soon
and we have a special lecture on the
note on the notion of time with craig
calendar
my colleague here at uc san diego which
is in person back
in the spring and anthony aguirre our
colleague up
in uc santa cruz i can't wait to share
all these with you so sit back
as we go into the impossible with dr
brandon hensley and yours truly dr brian
keating enjoy
and just to highlight the importance of
it
the search for cosmic microwave
background b mode polarization is
incredibly
interesting to cosmologists
and astroparticle physicists around the
world to
hopefully unravel our cosmic origins or
perhaps reveal information about
the primordial universe and the
fluctuations that led to it but equally
important are
perhaps the presence of tiny departures
from lorentz
in variants that may signal departures
from
the fundamental symmetries that underpin
both quantum mechanics and relativity as
a whole
and these are symmetries that are
perhaps held even more dearly
than is uh the symmetry
that underpins the uh the theory
of cosmic inflation so in some sense uh
detecting a departure from lorenzen
variance or parity violation
these are would be even more
revolutionary stupendous and exciting
for cosmic uh cosmologists such as
ourselves
and our colleagues around the world with
telescopes like the simon's observatory
simon's array act by separate etc
so uh with that i'm going to turn it
over to brendan hensley is a long
time friend and a brilliant uh intellect
and also i don't know if uh brandon's
aware of this but uh
lyman spitzer of course was the uh
progenitor and the namesake
of the spitzer space telescope he was a
professor at princeton university
but he's also the father of lyman
of lyman spitzer's the father of
nicholas spitzer as a professor at uc
san diego
of neurobiology so i find that very
exciting
and he's a friend of mine as well anyway
with that i turn it over
uh to dr brendan hensley thank you
brennan
well thank you so much brian i'm really
really pleased to be here today and
really and do wish i
got to join you in san diego but
hopefully sometime sometime soon
and no i didn't know that about lyman
spitzer's son that that's really neat
um so uh brilliant
introduction to what i'm going to talk
about today in terms of you know the
importance of cosmic birefringence and
recently there was a
claimed hint of this cosmic
birefringence signal
at kind of the 2.5 sigma level
looking at doing a re-analysis of the
planck data with a pretty clever
technique
for how to tease out this birefringent
signal
however um as with the search for
primordial b modes one thing that we
have to worry about
is what the dust in our galaxy is doing
and whether it can create signals that
might interfere with our inference
um of of these primordial signals so
i i'm going to now leave the high
redshift universe and and
spend most of my talk here in our galaxy
and
i i decided to prepare a few slides
before diving into the paper because
it requires a little bit of build up of
kind of what's going on in the
interstellar medium
to to appreciate the the tests that
we're doing
in this paper where we think we have
pretty compelling evidence that we now
understand how that one
dust is creating these parity violating
signals
and the two that it's related to the
fact of how
uh structures in the ism are arranged
into
into these filamentary structures um and
which
has implications for these studies of
cosmic
um so i'm going to go through the the
the
the uh let me see slides okay they're
working now
so so the motivation for these slides is
really just to try to give you a kind of
schematic
it's really a geometric picture of what
we think is going on with with these ism
filaments
um to kind of set up the analysis that
we do in the paper and then
we can walk through that in some detail
um and so
indeed so the main takeaway is that we
provide
observational evidence that this kind of
filament model
on that explains the dust edba symmetry
the te correlation
and the non-zero tb is in fact correct
and we can use this framework to make
predictions for the uh eb
correlation uh in in the polarized
estimation
um so i don't know what uh your usual
protocols are but i'm certainly happy to
be interrupted at any time
with questions so please do that
okay so the first thing to appreciate is
where dust polarization actually comes
from to begin with
and you need two ingredients in order to
get dust polarization
one is that your dust screens have to be
aspherical
so like here have it illustrated as a as
a football because i find that easy
easiest to think about um
because the aspherical grain so your
wavelengths that are much
larger much longer than the sizes of
your grain so typical interstellar dust
screen is about 0.1 microns
you know we're talking about millimeter
wavelength so the photon wavelengths are
very long
and so the grain actually uh
both absorbs and emits photons
preferentially with electric field
oscillating along its long axis
rather than short axes and so that gives
an individual grain
a sense of polarization
in the radiation that it emits but if
you just had a collection of randomly
oriented dust screens
even if they were all aspherical you
wouldn't get any net polarization
because it all averaged out unless they
were systematically aligned
and so what happens is that uh first the
dust screens tend to rotate about their
short axes
if you've ever tried to throw a football
you will know that it's much harder to
get the football to rotate
around its long axis you know a nice
spiral than it is to
tumble about its short axes so things
tend to prefer to rotate about its short
axis
and then the short axis which is the
rotation axis of the grain
tends to align uh with a local magnetic
field
and this is due to effects of
paramagnetic dissipation
basically a rotating grain
that is made out of some paramagnetic
material has some
unpaired electrons in it when it rotates
it will get magnetized develop a
magnetic moment along the
rotation axis and then the magnetic
field is going to exert a torque
on that magnetic moment in every
configuration except in the
configuration
where the angular momentum vector is
aligned
parallel to the magnetic field so that
rotational kinetic energy associated
with
j not parallel to b gets dissipated away
as heat such that over time
the rotation axis which is the short
axis gets aligned with the local
magnetic field
and then the sense of polarization is
perpendicular to magnetic field lines
since the long axis is perpendicular to
the field and that's the
orientation it likes to emit its photons
so that means that if we observe dust
polarization
and can measure the dust polarization
angle we could do a really good job
at tracing the um orientation of
galactic magnetic fields
and you know that certainly has emerged
as a very powerful probe especially
within the last decade with
observations from plank and then at
shorter wavelengths with things like
sofia
okay so that's the number one ingredient
is that uh
dust grains are aligned with magnetic
fields and that's what gives us the dust
polarization
the second observational fact that we
need here
is the fact that dust and gas are well
coupled so certainly
in the diffuse atomic medium where most
of your hydrogen is in atomic rather
than molecular form
about 40 percent of the sky and
basically anything that you're going to
look at and try to analyze in a
cosmological analysis
um the the mass ratio of dust to gas
is relatively constant so in this plot
from an earlier paper of mine
just showing the correlation between the
the dust reddening
so how much um optical photons um
dust absorbs versus the hydrogen
condensing just how much h1 gas you have
along the line of sight and you see that
they have a very strong correlation
you know deviations are kind of the 10
level or less
and some of that might actually just be
due to the ebv measurements rather than
the intrinsic tightness of that
correlation
so uh for much of the the sky that
uh we would be analyzing for cosmology
if we know the hydrogen column we can
make a pretty good guess at how much
dust we have
on that line of site uh the the next
datum that we need to to get this
picture
is the fact that the gas is arranged in
filaments that are coupled to
the magnetic fields so to understand
this if you consider
a blob of gas as on the screen here
sitting in a magnetic field if you have
any kind of mhd turbulence
any kind of shear it's a lot easier to
stretch that thing along field lines
than it is to move anything
perpendicular to field lines
such that over time you would end some
end up with something that gets kind of
elongated
along magnetic field lines and so the
the idea here is if we can see
these little filamentary gas structures
in our
um h1 emission data then that is another
probe of galactic magnetic fields since
these little h1 filaments
tend to be preferentially elongated
along the field lines
organized into these linear structures
and so you might be wondering how that's
possible
because i'm talking about neutral atomic
gas so how does
neutral gas know about magnetic fields
and this is a phenomenon that's called
flux freezing
even in the atomic gas
in the interstellar medium the
ionization fraction it doesn't have to
be very high
you know we're talking i think less than
10 to the minus four ionization
fractions
um are sufficient for the ions and
neutrals to be collisionally coupled to
each other
so the ions are tied to the field and
then the ions are also collisionally
coupled to the neutral so effectively
the magnetic field lines get frozen into
the gas the neutrals are coupled to the
field as well
so so even though we're talking about
mostly neutral gas it does
still know about about these magnetic
field lines and thus about dust
polarization
and so um this is work that is pioneered
by susan clark who's the lead on the
paper
that i'll be talking about today of
using the morphology of h1 maps
to deduce these filament orientations
and this is
using a technique from machine vision
known as the huff transform and
generalized to the rolling half
transform
where basically you take raw data so
this is
h1 emission um
uh at some particular h1 velocity
and we're going to take that data and
we're basically just going to look for
lines in that data so we're going to
high pass filter it
and then see if there's any directions
relative to some you know given pixel
where if you look along a line then you
see emission that
that is correlated along that line
and so basically you take this you apply
this transform and you get an image out
that looks like this
where now essentially this has picked
out all of the linear
features in this image and so the idea
would be
is if we're able to apply this
transformation to our h1 data
we are essentially picking out the
filaments and therefore picking out the
magnetic field lines
and so you know this particular little
filament it seems like it's oriented in
this direction
so we would guess in this region of the
sky the magnetic field
is oriented like that and that would
also allow us to predict what the
the dust polarization angle is
um so in um susan clark and colin hill
and collaborators
showed that this actually works
extremely extremely well in reproducing
the
morphology of the polarization angles in
the dust as seen by plank for instance
so at the top you have in this you know
the van gogh
style line integral convolution method
of of
plotting these magnetic field lines uh
magnetic field orientation just
completely inferred from this h1 data
just from 21 centimeter emission from
neutral hydrogen
and applying this algorithm and finding
where all the linear structures are
and then saying that those trace the
magnetic field and if you compare that
to the dust polarization angles from
flank you see
a very good agreement and these little
white vectors that you're seeing on here
are actually where we have measurements
of stellar polarization
and uh it's the same dust that gives us
the stellar polarization this gives us
the
the far infrared polarized emission and
those polarization angles
agree very well as well
so um in 2019 susan i had a paper where
you kind of
took the the next step in this is you
know
you know not only can we predict these
angles we can actually just predict
the total level of emission as well
using the fact that the
the dust and gas are well coupled so if
you know how much
gas you have you know how much dust you
have and so we created
these synthetic h1 based q and u maps
where again the the angle information is
just coming from
this filament finding idea and then the
the
total polarized intensity is just coming
from how much
hydrogen gas you have and so this is
just our maps of q and u
purely from the h1 data and then this is
the
planck 353 gigahertz q and u maps
and you see that the h1 data just by
itself
and there's no parameter tuning or
anything like
that in there the only thing is that the
maps aren't even in the same units so
there's some overall
one number scale factor applied to the
whole map um
but you see that the the h1 data just by
itself is able to reproduce
so much of what we see in the polarized
dust emission
in in the planck data
okay another
useful tidbit before we dive into the
paper is
uh about the e to b asymmetry so
one of the things that was kind of
surprising that planck found when
analyzing
um the the polarized dust emission is
that if you do
the standard e and b mode decomposition
you find that dust generates about twice
as many
e modes as b modes and this was not
something that
had been predicted a priority
and so we took our h1 maps so we have h1
i
q and u maps and we're able to compute
the vde
ratio in those maps and what we find is
a
very good agreement with what is seen in
plank so
this is the uh the single number that
best fits the planck data over this
multiple range over the mask that we
used which was just half the sky
and this was our l by l measurement
of the the b to e ratio just in our pure
h1 maps
and it's kind of remarkable that one is
able to do this without any kind of dust
modeling at all we've really only said
that
the dust is following whatever the gas
is doing
both in terms of the orientation and in
terms of just the
the total intensity so this
is pretty strong confirmation of
a kind of filament interpretation of of
the dust emission
so go back to this paper from 2001 by
mathias zaldariaga
has a very nice explanation of
the deep composition into emp modes of
emission in an elongated density
structure
so now you can imagine each of these
little tubes here is one of our h1
filaments
and then the little vectors in there are
just saying how the magnetic field
is oriented relative to the
the filament itself or really how the
the sense of polarization which is set
by the magnetic field for the dust
emission
and so what he showed was that in these
first two cases
where you have the magnetic fields
or the sense of polarization either
perpendicular to
or parallel with the filaments this
produces emo polarization whereas if you
have
um your sense of polarization is tilted
at a 45 degree angle
relative to your um your density
structure
then this gives you preferentially b
mode uh polarization
and so this really aligns with our
expectations from these interstellar
filaments
where you know we have these elongated
density structures that we think the
magnetic field is running parallel to
and so our polarization is perpendicular
to these filaments which gives us mostly
uh e-mode polarization so maybe it's not
surprising after all
that the dust produces more emotes than
b modes
and also we get a very strong
correlation between
the temperature and the emo polarization
in the polarized dust emission
um this this is all very naturally
explained
in this filament picture and it's also
very gratifying to be able to reproduce
this
just with the pure h1 data without doing
any any kind of
dust modeling because really that does
rely on kind of this
this filament picture so now the
question is what about
tb so we can understand that we get this
te correlation from from the fact that
our magnetic fields are threading
these filaments but tb is a little bit
uh more difficult to understand in this
context
uh there's uh from planck there was some
hints that the
dust emission had non-zero tv and a
paper from
island at all in 2019 that did a number
of tests on this to kind of
assess its robustness and it really
seems like at least at
large angular scales the polarized dust
emission indeed
has a preferentially positive non-zero
tb
um it was shown by kevin huffenberger
and collaborators that this
could be explained if instead of the
magnetic field
perfectly threading this filament you
had a slight
offset um in the angle
of the orientation of the filament
versus the magnetic field so just like
the
in the image i showed you previously if
you have your um
magnetic field at an oblique angle to
your filament and that can generate some
b mode
polarization but in order to have
a robustly positive or negative tb
across a large area of the sky then that
means that all of your
filaments would have to be rotated
relative to your magnetic field
preferentially
in one direction or the other so they're
all tilted you know five degrees
counterclockwise on average or five
degrees clockwise
on average to be able to see the level
of tb
that we observed and so that certainly
was not expected one would say if you
have you know a ton of these
little interstellar filaments and
they're all gonna you know even if
you know it's not uncommon to have an
offset between the filament axis and the
magnetic field
um you know by the time you average over
all the elements
all the all the filaments why would you
have any persistent
um sense of twist
or angle offset left
so so that was what was a bit unclear
um it was also emphasized by this
huffenberger at all paper
that if this is the explanation
for dust tb then it necessarily implies
that the dust eb is non-zero
and that's what the potential problem is
for birefringence analyses
that typically assume that the intrinsic
eb correlation from the galaxy is zero
um
so how can we
study this parity violation in the dust
emission
and assess whether or not it's really
coming from this kind of misaligned
filaments
picture and so um in this paper what we
really have are two independent measures
of each of these angles so from our h1
maps that i've introduced
we have already measured the orientation
of the filaments
on the sky so we we know this angle
and then from the planck 353 gigahertz
polarization data
we know what the dust polarization angle
is and therefore we think we know what
the
magnetic field orientation is so we can
actually measure for every pixel
on the sky what the angle difference is
between our filament orientation and our
dust polarization angle and if this
picture is right
then we should see that this delta theta
this
signed difference between these two
angles and
the signed is important because remember
has to be a systematic you know
clockwise twist or a systematic
counterclockwise twist
so we can make we can map this um this
delta theta and it should be predictive
of what's going on
uh in the dust tb so that's kind of the
the setup um before i dive into
the the paper itself is there any
questions or anything i should go back
over
you just talk about
how tv would originate from the
mechanism
um how how a tb is generated
yeah yeah so um i i
i won't be able to to derive the math on
the spot but uh
the zaldariaga paper does a really nice
job of it
uh showing that if you imagine you had a
single
just one filament and a sense of
polarization so
one filament in temperature or total
intensity
and the sense of polarization for
emission coming from that filament
is oriented at obliquely to that
filament so at 45 degree angles where
you get maximum
tb correlation then you you
preferentially produce a
b mode polarization and that's a um
tb signature the the tricky thing about
tb is you know it
this the sign is what matters here um
you know for te we naturally expect
every single filament on the sky
to have the magnetic field threading uh
the filament it's not going to be you
know half of them are
are um you know parallel to the filament
and half of them are
perpendicular it's going to be they're
all parallel whereas you know in this b
mode picture you know you could say okay
well yes
sometimes maybe you'll have a 45 degree
or 5 degree or whatever
inclination between your magnetic field
and your filament
but you would expect that to average to
zero after you averaged over a bunch of
filaments because there's no reason why
that
you know five degree offset ought to be
have the same sign
for every single filament either
clockwise or counterclockwise
so that's why we wouldn't have expected
any any tb correlation
thanks
okay so let me see if i can
switch things elegantly
all right can you see the paper
yep excellent
okay right so the origin of parity
violation and polarized dust emission
and implication for
cosmic birefringence so we claim that we
think
you know we understand the origin of
this pair evaluation
we think that um you know we demonstrate
that this is coming from these
misaligned filaments
um so the first thing that we
uh show in this paper is the fact that
the
the tb correlation as measured
is robust so here
is a measurement of the 353 gigahertz
cross 353 gigahertz tb
correlation um in the planck data so
this is now using
the n-pipe maps rather than the the pr3
maps
and you see its tv is pretty robustly
positive
you know from about l of 100 to 500 or
so
um so that seems pretty solid
um and this black line is a a fit
not to these data but to uh
it was from the plank paper fit to the
um
the exact data that they used and you
see
here the magnitude of tb is about what
we see here
um using the input maps um
but you know we can assess the
robustness of this to various
systematics by swapping out some of
these maps
so the 353 gigahertz polarization map is
pretty much the
best dust polarization map that we have
that's uh
you know over a very large sky area so
not really much to be done there but we
have lots of maps of dust
intensity that we could use as the t and
this tb correlation
so we tried it with the planck 857
gigahertz data
and also using the the h1 maps and in
every case we see what appears to be
a preference for a positive tb
correlation and so you know
we think that this is real and this is
astrophysical and now let's see if we
can
understand what's going on here
all right so the two figures here um
on the right here this figure three is a
plot of this
delta theta that i introduced in the
slides so this is taking the signed
angle difference
between our little h1 filaments that
we've identified
and then the 353 gigahertz polarization
angle
and this is what we claim will be
predictive of what the
tb is doing and now you'll be able to
see rather immediately
that you know there's not a lot of large
scale structure in this map
um you know this delta data is kind of
all over the place
so you know
this will have some implications for
thinking about how to mask this
okay and then on the left here is kind
of a visual explainer
of what we think all of these different
correlations ought to be doing
as we consider a rotation angle between
the filament
and the magnetic field orientation
so if the magnetic field and the
filament are perfectly lined up with
each other which i would say it's kind
of the standard case
then we'll see a robustly positive te
correlation
and no um t e or sorry no
uh tb or eb uh correlations
um that those will just uh all
average out um
it was gratifying to see that um when we
looked for
tb in our h1 maps alone so
um h1 intensity cross h1
b modes constructed from our synthetic q
and u maps we didn't see any
tb correlation and that makes sense
because those maps were
constructed under the assumption that
the filament axes
are the polarization angle
so that gives us zero tb equation for
h1s and so these actually are
um this angle let me explain that so
the the the zero is kind of just the out
of the box
um h1 maps and then we can imagine
applying a global rotation
over the whole map to our polarization
angles
so i'm going to take the polarization
angle in every pixel and i'm going to
rotate it
by some angle and you know some sine
angle either clockwise or
counterclockwise
and what i find what we find when as we
rotate this angle
we start generating the
tb and eb correlations so
you know start to to rotate this angle
in one direction
then eb and tb become positive
so now you know every single you know
filament is now offset by its magnetic
field by some
you know uh angle counterclockwise here
and the more we do that the the um
greater
the um tb signal we generate is
and also the te signal goes down
because we're kind of moving into that
regime from the zelda area 2001 paper
where
now the you know the filament axis and
then the magnetic fields at the 45
degree angle
to eventually where the tb is maximum
and then the t
e is zero um and then the eb
is also zero in that case and then
it goes back as we rotate it back to
pi over two and the same thing negative
so um this is a very nice you know
purely from the data
demonstration that as we apply a global
rotation to
all the polarization angles over this
map which is effectively
you know because we're not changing the
intensity maps all the intensity
structures are
you know stay put where they are we're
just rotating the polarization angles
relative to these intensity structures
and we're able to generate tb
uh and eb correlations just from doing
that
okay so now can we construct an
empirical test
that convinces us that this angle
difference
between the h1 filaments and the planck
measured magnetic fields is really know
something
about the about tb and so what we do
here
is um let me go back to this map quickly
so we take this map of our delta theta
which is the observed quantity
and we would say that one sine of delta
theta should be associated with one sign
of tb so as we rotate you know clockwise
we'll
go here and as we rotate
counterclockwise we'll go here
and then the other sign will be
associated with the
the other sign of tb so the idea
um that we had was okay why don't we
take
you know half the map that has the the
positive
delta thetas and keep those exactly the
way they are
but then for the part of the map that
has the negative delta thetas
we'll just mix them up we'll just apply
a random rotation to every pixel
and so the idea is that we'll destroy
any
tb correlations associated with these
negative
delta thetas and keep only the ones
associated with the positive
delta thetas and so that should really
boost our
tb signal and if we do the opposite
destroy all of the positive ones and
keep only the negative ones
then we should again boost our tv signal
but it should have the opposite sign
because we've gone from you know this
branch of tb
down to this branch of tb
and so that would be our our
observational test um
you know maybe the most elegant thing
that one could have done would just be
to
mask all the negative ones and take the
power spectrum of all the positive ones
but
one look at that mask and you'll see
exactly why that's not practical you
know
it's uh there's just so much small scale
structure in there you'd never be able
to
construct a sensibly sensibly behaving
mask
so that's why we've done this angle
randomization idea
and so um so we do that so we
construct some null tests where we
rather than select
on the positive or negative we choose
you know just random pixels and you know
we don't really uh we see something
that's mostly consistent with our
original map which is good and then we
do our two tests
uh one where we keep um
just our um positive angles and one
where we keep just our negative angles
and scramble uh the rest and what we see
is that in one case we see this robustly
positive tb
correlation much larger than what is
seen in the original data
and then in the other case you know not
only do we destroy that correlation but
we actually make it negative
by keeping only these negative delta
thetas um
you see this robustly negative um tb
correlation when we only keep our
our negative angles and so that tells us
immediately
that it really is this delta theta that
knows
what the sign of tb ought to be
because you know just just by so you
know choosing which pixels that we
do our analysis on by virtue of the sign
of delta theta
we're able to generate either robustly
positive or robust the negative
tv signals as it would be hard to
understand how this could be the case
unless this underlying filamentary
picture uh is the correct one
we're explaining um these correlations
so we can do the same thing uh with eb
um so
you know this plot demonstrates very
nicely
um that as we generate tb correlations
we also generate
eb correlations and so when we measure
these eb signals on our maps where we've
destroyed the correlations and half the
pixels
we find that indeed we can generate very
large both positive
and negative eb signals
much you know the the null is consistent
with zero the original maps are
consistent with zero
but by selectively applying rotations to
these positive or negative delta theta
pixels
uh we can get these either positive or
negative um
ep signals that have the sign exactly as
we would expect
so this is good in the sense that
this gives us a lot of confidence that
this filament picture is the correct one
but that also means that given the fact
that we do observe a positive tb
correlation in the sky
that the eb correlation in the sky is
going to be positive and non-zero
as well
any questions on that before i move to
the kind of image d simulations
portion of this
um i was wondering if you have a sense
of why there's like a peak around
l of 300 or so or you know what the
angular dependence is
yeah why there's this little feature um
yeah i'm not 100
sure what is going on there um
i don't know if it's just a a fluke
fluctuation
in the original map um
it would probably be my guess i mean um
okay sure yeah i i don't i don't think
there's any
or are you saying why does it go back
down to zero yeah or like you know why
is there a peak
yeah so i i mean it certainly is um
and we'll talk about the scale
dependence a little bit in a bit but
um you know we're really talking about
you know physical filamentary structures
in the ism that are going to have some
characteristic size
and some characteristic aspect ratio um
it's not ridiculous to think that
there's going to be some scale
dependence
to this correlation um you know
some level also matter you know how much
you're you're averaging down by looking
at the
uh the very large scales on your
two or more filament terms kicking in
versus looking more at single filaments
um
and then i think some of this will also
just be
noise in the polarization data as well
so i would say that
from what we see i wouldn't read too
much into the detailed
scale dependence i think we'd be
hard-pressed to say that
it's anything other than flat but
we certainly don't expect in detail for
the scale dependence to be flat in l and
i think that'll be one of the
interesting things to really follow up
on
and see if we can measure because it
absolutely measures for these
birefringence
measurements whether you're
parameterizing this as a scale-dependent
thing or not
oh yeah definitely you know that's what
i'm thinking in terms of if you're going
to try to remove it so
um okay thanks and then i just had
another question on that map above where
you showed the angles
um i was actually a little surprised to
see so much
red and blue uh i guess i thought maybe
you know maybe it's just maybe this is
an incorrect interpretation but it
looked like there are
there's a lot of misalignment um
relative to what i would expect
uh you know in this picture of the gas
aligning
along the magnetic field line so do you
have a sense of
why there's so much misalignment as
opposed to like the naive picture of
just
they're all aligned right so this
actually is a good segue
into the next part of this where we
actually look at this in mhd simulations
and i would say that uh as it happens
the amount of
misalignment that we're seeing here is
not all that unusual
um relative to you know what is seen in
the actual ism simulations
so the ism is turbulent and messy uh
there's a lot going on um so it's
perhaps not
uh you know i don't i i wouldn't have
been able to predict eight
you know what the dispersion in angles
should be or anything like that
but it's perhaps not surprising that
strong misalignments are
are not uncommon and i should also say
that when you get into really dense gas
and this will become important in a
second
you can actually get into the regime
where
the um alignment is actually the
opposite you're more of one of these
situations
but if you have a lot of gas that piles
up
along field lines so you start kind of
making a pancake
and that gives you a filament that's
perpendicular to your field lines
and so that's something that can happen
in very high density regions
um and that could give you negative te
correlations in these high density
regions which there's kind of some hints
of
in blank data so
in reality there's a whole spectrum of
you know very clean nicely threaded
filaments with a magnetic field and
you know a lot of turbulent motions and
whatnot
making things a lot more complicated
sure i see okay thanks
yeah um yeah and then there's also
uh i guess you could you can see by a
little bit of
3d if sorry a little bit of um coherent
uh where it's particularly white
particularly close to zero
in kind of these large areas and that's
actually
related a bit to the 3d effects whereas
on a single line of sight you might be
looking at multiple
filaments and so you're only measuring
one
you know dust polarization angle that's
kind of the weighted average of
everything you're seeing along the line
of sight
and so that's another way that things
can be different
so these these are actually these
preferentially white regions are
highlighting regions of particularly
low polarization fractions
okay so let me talk about the mhd sims a
little bit since we since we got into
that
um so that's this figure here so we're
looking at
um so this is real data
using the in-pipe data using the 857
gigahertz for temperature because it's
the highest signal to noise being at the
highest frequency
and then 353 gigahertz e b and then
these are
msg simulations put together by changu
kim um
so using the tigris code so this is like
a huge
slice of a galactic disk
kind of one kpc by one kpc in the disk
and then seven
kpc above and below the disk because
it's kind of a
huge rectangular slices
of galaxy and he has a lot of these um
it's a full mhd with star formation and
self gravity
it's really done to study the
interstellar physics but
you know what what he has found is that
he does a pretty good job at simulating
you know what we see in cmb data
by putting a little observer inside his
simulation cubes and saying oh what does
the sky look like to this observer
and the virtue of this or one of the
many virtues really
is the fact that we can get a ton of
different skies just by
putting this little observer in
different places in the galactic plane
and then also just by the fact that
these are time dependent simulations
and so he in previous work has shown
that things even like the e to b
asymmetry
can have a time dependence to them
that's you know necessarily generically
get this
two to one that you know it depends a
little bit on if a supernova has gone
off near you recently
and kind of you know moved everything
around a bit
or or whatnot so he gets a a wide range
of skies that don't have
necessarily the statistics of the sky
that we
we know and love okay so
um this is showing um uh the cross
correlations
um between um
these various quantities in the impipe
data and then um
also the uh the simulation
maps and the this lets us
do things like test in detail um
whether we see the expected correlations
between say
tb uh and eb um
for instance in the in the simulations
um
so let me see if i can yeah so
i think this is this is possibly more
illustrative than
just uh throwing off all the
correlations on there
so if we are in a scenario like we are
in the real sky where we measure this
positive t
e correlation then the correlation
between
t b and e b is positive
and so if we just take his um this
you know each one of these dots is a
different simulation or at least a
different observer
in a simulation at a particular snapshot
and measure what the tb correlation is
and what the eb
correlation is in the dust emission
then we see very strongly this positive
correlation between
eb and tb as predicted
um
right and then so this is between eb and
tb
and then this is between eb and te and
now
on by virtue of these simulations we
also got some skies
where the te is preferentially negative
we just happen to be more you know have
more in the regime of
filaments perpendicular to to field
lines for instance
um and in this case if we go back
to this figure here so if tb
or sorry te is positive like we see in
the sky
robustly positive then um
tb and eb are positively correlated
as long as we're close to zero on this
plot we'll just see a positive
correlation but if we go to somewhere
where on t e is negative
then you'll see that the
tb and eb are negatively
correlated and that's exactly what
we're seeing in these simulations where
now we're going to
um skies that have this negative te
and we're seeing this negative
correlation now between
tb and eb and so this
very much goes what we would expected
just from the
interstellar filament picture
um maybe the other thing to note is that
um across these simulations the e to b
ratio is reasonably stable i would say
not a lot of variation in it um but
eb and tb and and te really
um all can have substantial variations
and so kind of the way to we've wrapped
our minds around this
is is really you know there isn't some
you know intrinsic party violating
physics
in the dust emission itself um
or in the mhd or whatever it really just
is just the
realization of the sky that we happen to
get sitting in our particular location
in the galaxy
that you know there's enough stochastic
variation in this that it doesn't all
just average down to zero and we get a
little bit left over
and whether that little bit left over
happened to be a positive tb or a
negative tb
was more or less up to chance and we got
what we happen to get
um but the good thing about that is you
know assuming this is the right
underlying picture is that by measuring
this td
we can predict what what the eb is
and so that's what the the last portion
of the paper
is focusing on is thinking about this
in terms of the birefringence analyses
and particularly this
um paper by um komatsu in 2020
who made a tentative claim um for a
cosmic birefringence um
so in this image here
essentially what we've done is
you know applied a mask to the data so
this is our
uh or the planck 70
galaxy mask that we use in all of our
default analyses
and we measure a tb and um
we can convert that into an
angle if i can find that right
so we can convert that into an angle
which is effectively saying
you know how much do we have to
systematically misalign
the magnetic field from these filaments
in order to produce a tb
signal as large as what we measure um
so you know a huffenburger at all did a
similar
kind of analytic calculation and they
they found that you know five degrees
um seemed to be enough that if you know
you had
uh um kind of a five degree preference
for a clockwise rotation versus the
counterclockwise rotation
um then then that would give you the eb
or sorry that would give you the tb
um of the size that we measure and so
this is taking the
tb that we measure over this specific
mask and saying how big of an angle is
it
and indeed we see something that's about
five degrees
and it's important to under you know to
emphasize that this is much much much
larger than the quota systematic
uncertainty
on the the angle calibration you know
down there
at point a few degrees and also much
larger than the
uh cosmic birefringence angle that was
quoted is also something like point a
few degrees
so we're really seeing something like
five degrees so if
if the manami and kamatsu analysis had
been on this
mask and we had seen a robustly positive
tb that could be contributing a robustly
positive eb
to the dust emission then we would have
said oh
so actually the monomial komatsu result
is a lower limit on cosmic birefringence
and their
detection or their their hint is
actually a little bit more
statistically significant than they
quoted
because this would only serve to make
that
smaller rather than larger i
and then all would be great however um
they didn't do their analysis on this
mask
they did their analysis on this mask so
they're much more aggressive
in terms of how deep into the galactic
plane that they are reaching
so using kind of 90 of the sky rather
than
70 of the sky and when we compute
tb over this mass we don't get this nice
robustly positive
tb we see tb that maybe is positive at
large scales
and maybe dips negative and then maybe a
zero
uh it seems a much more complicated
and certainly has some non-trivial scale
dependence to it
and so we can't really
say too much quantitative about the um
komatsu analysis because we don't see a
very cleanly behaved
tb signal and so
this really underscores one of the
points that we try to make in this paper
is that you know given the the origins
of this tb
signal and the consequent eb signal is
that your answer is going to be really
mask dependent
um depending on just what part of the
the galaxy you happen to be looking at
um and so you know one of the things
that we recommend it would be nice to
to redo the analysis on a mask like this
where the tb
is a lot a lot better behaved and
doesn't have this really strong scale
dependence
um since the data are public can you
just do that analysis and
um i i mean i one certainly could i
don't know that i could
sit down and implement it out of the box
but i'm sure that there's somebody
working on it
right now
and would definitely be a very
interesting thing to do
i don't know how much the i mean
presumably they went to this very
aggressive sky mask because they needed
all the signals and noise so i don't
know
if one will get into to difficulties on
that account
that's right
um right so um the things to emphasize
here yes is this is this is very mass
dependent but
you know it you know we can measure tb
um over you know at least we have a
reasonable sky area
and uh we um can make sure that we're
doing these analyses
on on mask where this is well behaved um
but i think you know the real answer is
to um
implement this a you know full
likelihood approach
taking into account any possible scale
dependence of
of this uh correlation because we
certainly don't
you know looking at this you would say
okay that doesn't look like there's any
uh very dramatic scale dependence over
you know kind of the 100 to 500
l range but um again this is coming from
real interstellar filaments that have
real physical sizes and they'll have
some
size and distance distribution so this
will almost certainly have
some skill dependence once we dig in far
enough
so really should be
accounted for in any analysis as well
oh yeah so i just have a quick question
on you know if
on how exactly to account for that so is
it possible to basically just
you know give it the sky mask i mean so
really they use cl
e beat right to estimate the rotation
angle could you
could you basically give them here's the
cl eb we expect
from from dust and could they run that
through their pipeline and generate the
angle
based solely on dust they would expect
i mean i think that's effectively um
i mean that's kind of what we do for the
the
the the mask here um although of course
it doesn't turn out into a nice single
angle
over over that full l range but i mean
this is us
you know translating uh these
measurements into
into a rotation angle
uh maybe yeah maybe i was a little bit
confused so is there a distinction
between the rotation angle
of the misalignment between the dust
or sorry the gas filaments in the
magnetic field versus like
a global rotation that would generate
you know eb um right right so
so when we're talking about this angle
here we really do mean it as kind of a
global rotation
so so naturally we would expect that
each filament to be doing its own thing
and the this this angle is only the
statistical thing that comes out at the
end that you end up
on average bias by this many degrees in
one direction or the other
and so that can be effectively
parameterized as a single global
rotation
but then that becomes degenerate with
any other kind of
global rotation of whether that be you
know just your polarization
angle is miscalibrated by a few degrees
or whatever
one direction or the other would also
look like this
um so one of the points that we make is
that this this number that comes out is
actually much larger than
that particular uncertainty yeah
okay
all right thanks
and i guess i should also say that um
you know given the fact that we do
measure
a um tb and
a te uh we can kind of use this picture
here
to to figure out you know where on these
curves that we fall and to estimate uh
what eb
is and um planck the planck data are not
sensitive enough
to to be able to measure the level of eb
that we predict um but it's also not
ridiculously low
so it's certainly something that could
be pursued with more sensitive data
i think that would i think it will be a
matter of time before we
we make the first dust eb detection
so it's exactly the opposite as in the
uh
cosmic case potentially where eb
dominates over tv if parity violation
well thanks brennan is at the end of
your presentation
yep that's uh i think you got through
everything unless there's any other
questions or
anything else to discuss
in terms of self-calibration you know
using the galaxy
essentially to null out cosmic fire
refrigerants
um there's you know one issue is that
we don't have a guarantee that there's
no uh you know cause
or not cosmic but you know astrophysical
polarization rotation
on galactic scales uh you know we
haven't really tested it
beyond our solar system really um
so you know is it a fraught proposition
to do as miami and camazo are suggesting
essentially to
use the galactic you know treat the
galactic contribution as
a calibrator calibration source
if indeed you know effects like this
could be
intrinsic i know they're treating it as
a lower limit and it would only get
stronger but
they're showing its mass dependence
knowing no one's been able to use the
galaxy as a that's just an emote
polarization calibration source to my
knowledge
violation calibrations
you know that's a a good and
and subtle question yeah i'm not i'm not
sure how far we will able to be
to push this but i mean i i think the
manami and komatsu approach
is a good one i think it just needs to a
little bit more sophistication to
uh to take into account these these
complications
great um okay so uh
for those watching on my youtube channel
i'm gonna put a link here
to a talk that i gave with sean carroll
following the komatsu paper results
about their interpretation if it's true
and you'll want to see that talk for
background from the person who came up
along with colleagues back in 1990
with the astrophysical implications of
cosmic polarization
rotation uh and so click this link over
here
i don't know if you can see me uh but
i'm pointing somewhere over here
and with that i want to thank brandon
very much and have a great rest of your
day
thanks for this wonderful talk it was a
pleasure thank you all
bye guys thanks brandon
thank you
you